[Music]
what do you guys think of the pope
well i don't think i think much of much
of it isn't there a news i heard about
this
this one's pretty cool you already know
what to do there's a new one right
you knew i mean he's not like really new
he's been new he's the guy from
argentina i think he's from argentina
we're still waiting for georgia to
figure out who the pope is yes
yes exactly he's not no they already i'm
just kidding
yeah so the reason why i'm asking why
you guys what you guys think of the pope
is that he is known to be a little more
progressive
than the previous pokemon oh he likes
he's the guy that said like the gay
peoples are coos
lgbt is okay yeah that was an exact
quote and he even talked about he
likened
uh eating and and taste to the same type
of players you get from sex
and how that's you know oh no because he
was a bouncer
oh yeah yeah yeah he was a club bouncer
that bouncer
is cool man this guy yes i like this
pulp already yeah so he's different
and you know a lot of people say oh he
just talks not like the other popes
because he's just talking to people on a
on a you know regular
human level yes and so he's a little bit
different
and um yes the most recent thing
really puts him in a category of his own
so certain things that popes aren't
supposed to do
is uh i don't know be caught up in a
scandal for example
he's in a scandal another he was also
the first pope to
to talk about like to address the whole
like
priest pedophilia oh why yeah what
actually what
what did he say that was my follow-up
question he condemned it or something
like he pretty much said something like
stop [ __ ] the kids yeah yeah but like
he had he actually acknowledged it yeah
dad no one is sure everyone kind of just
like turns the other away and be like
this no never mind you tell the story of
casey i'm sorry oh okay
okay so what's the scandal all right so
here's the pope's
instagram yes that's another thing that
he is different yo he's not following
nobody he's got social media
i wish he had a he followed the account
that said jesus
and that's the only one he was following
he has 969
posts yes and he's following zero
he deletes one every time he turns
upside down it still says 69.
that's fine upside down it's 696.696.
69. that's funny i didn't catch that
before so what do you guys think of his
content so it's got
you know obviously he's like and stuff
so the idea
is that he does not run this instagram
account obsessed i don't think he does
like he's like 80 something yeah it's
like the nuns that are like progressive
and she's another old catholic guy what
if he's an influencer he's taking brand
deals he has like
uh like nike robes
all right he's my promo code pope
all right so then big pulp
get mushroom king big pump yeah he's
gonna he's gonna have a post for the
mushroom kingdom
[ __ ] june hey joseph talks with the
pope francis so it's gonna be tight
that's true uh maybe you might want not
wanna be talking to the po for a brand
deal anytime soon so here we have
his account we've established that and
then
if we go to the next oh slide wait
what's that
he likes hey we have a picture of a
beautiful girl with our butt sticking
out and if you go
all the way down what does that say
right there liked
by francis yes she's wearing a catholic
school outfit so maybe
he was like good for her for getting
educated
communion yeah so this uh username
same as this username and a lot of
people are speculating
how the [ __ ] that that happened hey
here's the thing
the the the instagram algorithm that's
his second it's very predictive
dude the fact that he follows zero
people means that he's like
four pages that's true he went out of
his way to like this he went hashtag
he likes all of god's creatures he's
probably
not running his own account right true
he likes all of god's creatures
highly highly healthy your body is a
temple and he was like
and he's like get it girl empower
yourself
he liked it no i really doubt that he's
the one actually
he's not like donald trump in bed
[ __ ] doing his like twitters
yeah he runs his for sure yeah he for
sure it's kind of refreshing to see that
it is refreshing i kind of i'm kind of
on board i get it hey man do you
think bro what if it's like a social
media like uh
uh intern and it's like a it's like one
of those alter boys
that's like like trying to get them to
be more like with the times yeah yeah
and then he's running the account and he
signed into that account and he's just
like temptation on instagram oh my god
he's like 15.
what's happened within our own team like
one of the one of our team members like
they forgot to sign
out of the just kidding news
and then they'd be liking other videos
that booty shake twerkies
i don't know what kind of videos it does
happen yeah but like that would have 69
stuff like that yeah i don't remember
you search that on youtube dude you
don't if you need
instruction on how to 69 you got issues
yeah
[Laughter]
are popes are allowed to have sex no no
i think so their bodies for god he's got
to have a release right
yeah pastors
i don't think they're supposed to jack
off or come at all it's for sure
somebody else
right it's rough well now the vatican
has launched
the vatican has launched an
investigation now they're trying to
figure out who
on the day of november 14th
yeah investigate and then they they're
like let's study what he liked
and then we got to see her page everyone
yeah they're like
this is pretty good contest but her
followers are going up
like crazy oh sure yeah so the model's
name
the model's name is natalia garabotto
bottom
is she italian uh you know what i don't
know
do we know natalia
how did she how did he stumble upon her
you know i know
that's what i'm saying the explore page
for sure i don't think it was the
explore page i think it was
the fact that they searched for her it
sounds like italian
he sounds italian yeah maybe the pope
was showing this girl to somebody else
to like his co-pope and was like yo
check out [ __ ]
the funny thing is why would he like it
and he accidentally
said they were trying to zoom in they
actually liked it probably something
like you're scrolling and you hit
i did that on twitter before i
accidentally yeah i liked my own photos
before yeah yeah yeah
he does that and i was like i'm like i'm
like but if you don't kick this guy
if you don't have anyone does anything
pop up on your feed
that's the question i don't think
anymore right actually maybe
or let's try the explorer that means you
have to unfollow
everyone and then see if anything pops
up on your or you could just start a new
account yeah start a new account
i don't want to sign in oh yeah that's
that's harder than deleting everyone off
your account
and then i'll i'll i'll add again
because you gotta think about a new
password you have to think of a new name
and it's like a whole thing
shy guys i'd rather just look at
everyone i follow get a pen
and a pad and then write down their
names so then i don't lose it
yeah and then i i unfollow all of this
yeah i can just imagine joe doing that
makes me [ __ ] because i want to make
sure
that i don't lose the information right
that's true and digital things can be
deleted
you know earlier i said that you might
not want to be working with the pope
for a brand deal but you know what this
is actually really on brand with you
so in fact you should reach out to the
pope maybe
yeah yeah all that stuff i think i think
you're honestly very human
to like a pretty thing i don't know it's
about little boys or something you know
true pedophilia it's much better you
know he's like you know
at least he you know he likes girls in
that way
true so the model she she's tweeted out
this uh
situation too she's very honored she's
you know taking it very gracious she's
sliding into his dna it's always gonna
treat my mind as a little girl
to have the pulp thirst for me yeah and
my [ __ ] ass cheeks
at least i'm going to heaven and it's
like with her ass
oh my god and then uh she
wrote another tweet be right back i'm
i'm on my way to the vatican
champions like the pope's dick exactly
that's someone even commented the horny
trinity the father
the son and the holy would you look at
that
but yeah so that's the latest uh scandal
from the vatican
and on the vatican's that's we said that
they're
how are they investigating other than
like they're trying to figure out the
time stamp basically they're trying to
figure out who
came from his phone who was who assigned
it to
you see that on your own account they
you can
i don't know so they're hitting
having like some cyber team look at
everything yeah because i don't think
you can do it like within your own can't
you see your activity
yeah you could see the posts that you've
liked but you can't see a time stamp of
when it was like this sure
so they got it they got to be hitting up
instantly yeah i think they are for sure
yeah yeah because they have their own
army their own like secret agency their
own police it's
yeah i think probably see what phone it
was liked from
oh true yeah true so this is probably a
serious investigation
because the pope for sure isn't on
instagram like regularly if he has what
if he is though
that'd be tight he's like watching like
mukbang videos and [ __ ] he's actually
like
like listen to asmr before he does he's
watching barbara over here yeah what if
he got all his
hail mary's done early then he had a lot
of time to kill he's like yeah i guess i
guess i'll just you know what's funny is
that all of these are just people right
like all these world leaders or whatever
and they have time off too so what are
they doing
like and who are they watching for
entertainment that's what i want to know
is like on the side he's doing all these
like
you know jack off things yeah like
instagram was watching like buddhist
leaders and just straight talking [ __ ]
to them
account he's on joel olsen's instagram
he's talking
about all the other religious leaders
now [ __ ] you
he has all these fence does and [ __ ]
was that senator didn't he get popped
for having a a burner account or
something like that and he was like as a
gay black man and he goes on he's like i
don't feel support
you know i don't feel supported by one
of my followers that sent me that
message yikes and i was like shut up bro
but he went on another account to make
himself look good yeah
because people do that bro if kevin
durant got trouble that's what happened
he's in trouble for right yeah like
wait kevin durant kevin durant had like
like a couple
like he had like a crazy amount of uh
fake twitter pages yeah and he would
talk about like oh kevin durant's the
best
you're the greatest i don't i think it
was a similar situation like he got pop
for like i remember this was story i
don't know the specifics
but it's like if a guy like kevin durant
is doing this [ __ ] i'm sure
all these guys are everyone has
insecurities everyone everyone needs to
boost their own crazy you know like
whatever
it's it's maybe it's not the it's easy
to make fun of a guy for doing that [ __ ]
but at the same time it's like
you get it you know it's like what do
you expect i think it's just funnier
because we expect
these people in high positions to be
above it all yeah yeah like to not have
the insecurities we do yeah
yeah so so when they get to a certain
level you think like
they got it all together but kevin
durant has troll accounts yeah
still he's like kevin durant is the
greatest basketball player of all time
yeah and he writes like oh thank you man
he's like oh cool he retweets it
he has a conversation with himself oh
that's such a loser
that's funny when you're in the nba
bubble dude you gotta
see that that doesn't matter
they're all me me me and me and it's
probably he probably doesn't have to do
any of that you know because you'll have
people protecting him yeah
there's so many people arguing for him
for sure dude that
is crazy i'm i run joe's uh
like facebook yeah thank you is that
what it's called stuff that's a fake
instinct
okay i have that it's that nickname
what's a fake twitter
twitter twitter twitter apple twitter
[Music]
appleflutter
you